Salut ! Aujourd'hui, je vous parle depuis Mulhouse !
depuis l'Entrepôt Théâtre à Mulhouse !
où je joue ce soir, demain et après-demain !
La vidéo doit sortir à 17h, et il est exactement 16h05
je suis bien bien dans le timing comme il faut
le jeudi c'est le jour de "Je parle de ce que je veux"
mais cette semaine petit changement je vais parler de ce que vous voulez, vous !
et depuis hier sur Facebook-YouTube-Twitter, je vous ai demandé un thème pour cette vidéo-là
à partir du moment où c'était pas une astuce ou un truc de mentalisme
Y'a eu de très très bonnes idées que je garde pour plus tard
mais que je peux faire qu'à partir de chez moi
et ce matin il y a Marie Jérome qui m'a fait mourir de rire en disant :
"T'as qu'à parler de comment on fait quand on oublie une valise dans un train"
Oui parce que l'année dernière j'ai fait même pire que ça, j'ai mis ma valise dans le mauvais train
je suis sorti du train pour téléphoner et le train est parti
et il allait pas du tout à Paris, il allait à Nantes
ça m'a fait une connexion dans mon cerveau quand on a parlé de train
et de Mulhouse à l'Entrepôt Théâtre
la première fois que je suis venu jouer à Mulhouse
j'ai oublié mon Mac dans le train
et je l'ai retrouvé !
Et je pense que cette histoire va vous intéresser
je faisais donc le trajet Paris-Mulhouse en train avec mon diffuseur
on était tous les 2 avec Joakim dans le train
et on était tous les 2 l'un à côté de l'autre
et je regardais l'ordinateur
j'en ai eu marrre, j'ai éteint l'ordinateur
je l'ai mis sur le filet devant moi.
Arrivés à Mulhouse, on entend l'annonce
Joakim prend ses affaires,
je récupère aussi ma sacoche, mon manteau, ma valise
Et nous v'là descendu du train
Direction : L'Entrepôt Théâtre
Je commence à faire mes balances sur scène, à installer le matériel pour jouer le soir
Je me rends compte
que j'ai laissé le Mac sur la première place où j'étais précédemment
dans le filet
comme un imbécile, je l'ai oublié.
Question : Comment on fait pour retrouver un mac dans ces circonstances ?
Dans un premier temps, Joakim et Sarah
(Sarah, c'est la propriétaire de l'Entrepôt)
sont partis tous les deux à la gare pour aller voir si on avait déposé le mac aux objets trouvés
Evidemment......Que dalle !
J'enclenche le "localiser mon mac" sur mon iphone
qui permet comme ça de localiser ses affaires de plus ou moins près.
Et de faire apparaître un message ou de le verrouiller à distance ou de l'effacer à distance...
A condition qu'il reste de la batterie et qu'il soit connecté au Wifi
5 toutes petites minutes avant que le spectacle ne commence,
Je reçois une notification
Il vient de passer à côté d'un réseau Wifi que je connais
Peut-être un réseau Free
Et à ce moment précis, je sais que mon mac book pro est à Mulhouse
dans un bâtiment précis, et je sais quel bâtiment !
J'ai fait apparaître un message automatique via l'application
pour quand le personne ouvrirait le mac
avec mon numéro de téléphone, etc....
* Rires.... nerveux *
Il ne m'a pas.... tellement rappelé.
Mais je vais jouer le coeur léger, parce que je sais qu'on va récupérer ce mac
Je sais qu'on va le retrouver et qu'on n'aura pas de problème
Tout d'abord, avec Joakim
On a fait le point sur "Qui était dans le wagon avec nous à ce moment-là"
Qui était descendu ? Il ne restait pas grand monde
A nous deux, on a pu revisualiser quelles étaient les personnes
Les personnes âgées, y'avait un jeune, etc....
On s'est refait les entrées, les sorties des personnes :
Qui était sorti avant nous, après nous du train
Et le seul suspect potentiel était...
un jeune qui avait une vingtaine d'années
Il a ouvert l'ordinateur juste avant que je joue, donc :
à peu près à 20h20, 20h25
Ca ne collait pas avec notre heure d'arrivée qui était de 14h
Pour moi, à 20 ans, tu trouves un mac à 14h,
t'attends pas 20h30 pour essayer de voir s'il fonctionne
Ca colle par contre, si c'est quelqu'un qui travaille
et qui va attendre de rentrer chez lui pour pouvoir l'ouvrir
Et d'un coup, tous les soupçons se portent ...
Sur les personnes qui font le ménage dans le train !
Et on part donc sur cette piste-là, sur l'idée que c'est quelqu'un qui travaille dans ce train
J'vous rappelle que grâce à la localisation que j'avais eue durant quelques secondes
la veille à 20h20, j'avais un bâtiment très précis qui était situé dans Mulhouse
Nous partons donc à midi à ce fameux bâtiment
Pour trouver mon mac, potentiellement
On arrive donc sur un quartier
Bon... Pas le quartier bourgeois... Hein, on ne va pas se mentir
C'est plutôt un quartier un petit peu HLM, des gens dehors
ça a l'air sympathique et tout, ok
J'identifie bien le bâtiment, j'ai de la chance parce que y'a que 12 appartements dans le bâtiment
Je garde l'idée de la piste que c'est quelqu'un qui travaillait dans le train, et qui faisait le ménage du train
Et je frappe à la première porte, c'est une femme qui m'ouvre
Là, je fais, vraiment au culot, je lui dis :
"Bonjour, excusez-moi, j'ai eu votre adresse par la SNCF, c'est bien vous qui travaillez dans les trains ?
ou votre mari ? En fait, je ne sais pas... je n'ai pas très très bien compris"
Et la femme me dit que non, c'est pas elle du tout, qu'elle ne travaille pas du tout à la SNCF
et j'insiste vraiment : "Ben alors pourquoi on m'a donné cette adresse, enfin c'est quand même bizarre...?
Ou alors, c'est peut-être pas votre appartement, y'a quelqu'un qui travaille ici à la SNCF dans ce cas là ?
Je me suis peut-être juste planté de porte
C'est le fameux moment où elle me dit :
"Ah oui, oui, c'est vrai, on a un voisin qui travaille à la SNCF,
alors je ne sais pas quelle porte c'est, en fait on se croise plutôt devant...
Mais oui, oui, y'a un Monsieur dans le bâtiment qui y travaille
Et là, tu te dis : "Dis donc, c'est pas magique ça ?"
Je continue mon porte à porte avec une personne du dessus qui m'accueille un petit peu avec méfiance
Et puis quand je lui explique que l'on m'a donné l'adresse et puis que..
c'est un monsieur qui travaille là, qui n'est pas très très vieux, qui a une petite quarantaine d'années...
Il se détend, il cherche avec moi et il fait : "Ben allez demander à la jeune fille qui est en bas, elle connait tout le monde ici"
Je descends pour parler à la jeune fille qui est en bas
qui connait tout le monde ici, SAUF le mec que je cherche
Et là, je vois un mec qui sort de chez lui, il jette un regard vers moi,
il rejette un regard vers sa porte
Donc il est en train de faire un choix, une hésitation
Je fonce sur lui devant tous ses voisins, au milieu de tout le monde
J'vais le voir, dire : "Ah, enfin, je vous trouve,
c'est bien vous le monsieur de la SNCF qui a récupéré l'ordinateur
pour que je vienne le chercher ?"
Si c'est pas lui, c'est pas très grave, je ne risque pas grand chose
en l'occurence, c'est bien le mec de la SNCF
Il ne peut que assumer devant tous les voisins
et en plus, j'ai déjà parlé de l'objet de ma présence :
Venir récupérer l'ordinateur
Il me fait monter chez lui dans son entrée, dans son hall d'entrée
Et il me dit, je vais à la chambre et je reviens
Je me dis, on va éviter de se faire tuer quand même qu'il revienne avec un fusil à pompe
Je fais : "Oui oui, ben, écoutez, c'est vos employeurs qui m'ont donné votre adresse directement..
Ils m'ont dit que c'est vous qui l'aviez donc..
comme nous, on habite juste à côté, c'était plus simple de passer quoi"
Là, il a eu la petite phrase magnifique, la petite phrase de trop d'ailleurs,
qui a été de dire : "Vous avez de la chance que ça tombe sur moi hein, quand même...
ça aurait pu tomber sur quelqu'un de malhonnête..."
Ben c'est ce que t'es mon pote quand même...
Parce que tu t'es barré avec l'ordinateur
C'est pas très grave, mais bon
N'essaie pas d'avoir plus de remerciements quand même que ce que je suis en train de faire
Bref, je récupère le mac à ce moment-là
on repart avec Joakim, on attend d'être vraiment, vraiment, vraiment éloignés
pour réouvrir le mac et de voir qu'il fonctionne et que tout va bien
et on a récupéré.
Pour la petite anecdote croustillante de l'histoire
On est allé déposer des flys, et des invitations pour le spectacle,
ben le même spectacle que je joue là "Fabien Olicard vous mentalise"
Juste pour qu'il sache comment on avait remonté jusqu'à lui
C'était une petite satisfaction personnelle dans cette histoire de ouf
Vous m'avez demandé de parler d'une anecdote
Vous m'avez demandé de parler potentiellement de mes voyages en train
Vous m'avez demandé de parler de la tournée,
et bien, dans ce Jeudi de "Je fais ce que je veux"
J'aurais réussi à réunir les 3  !
Si cette petite histoire vous a plu, vous pouvez aussi me le faire savoir en mettant un ....
Pouce en l'air !!!!
Vous pouvez également commenter, je lis tous les messages
vous pouvez aussi vous abonner à la chaîne
et rendez-vous demain à 17h, pour le prochain Mental Vlog !
Tchao !